and it is indeed a good start to hear
some good news for the governor of ohio
last uh
yesterday at this time as a matter of
fact we were distressed to learn of
course that the governor tested positive
for the coronavirus
uh then lo and behold we discovered a
follow-up test he tested negative i hope
that's the accurate one
the governor now joins me governor good
to have you um
well you had us a little scared governor
uh what happened here
how did it go testing positive and then
a little later testing negative
well that's that's a great question uh
certainly scared me
uh i went to uh cleveland drove to
cleveland
uh to meet the president and of course
when you go meet the president you
get a test and they do a quick test uh
so they did do what's called an antigen
test and uh they came back very quickly
and said you're positive
and i said you know i'm very very
surprised by that
uh of course i couldn't see the
president so i called ohio state and uh
uh asked them you know what we should be
doing and they said well let's let's do
another test so
um you know we went down and uh my wife
and i and
several of people who around me all the
time got tests yesterday and then
last night it came back uh as as
negative they re-ran it again and it
came back as negative we're going to
take another test tomorrow
and we hope it comes back as negative as
well i mean i think
one of the things that i want people to
understand in ohio is we've had about
1.3 million
tests so far uh very very very few of
these are the antigen tests these are
relatively new tests
my understanding is that they actually
test the protein
uh that is on on the corona
virus itself and they're just not as
reliable they're very quick
uh but i'm told they're only about 70
percent
uh reliable so you know
they have a place but what i don't want
people in ohio or any place else to
think is that
uh you know these tests are not accurate
uh
the the test that i got is
at ohio state is the same test that
we've seen time and time again in ohio
and i'm told by the best scientists we
can find that they're 99 point whatever
percent accurate but that these
antigen tests do have a tendency to have
false positives
usually false negatives and they say
it's unusual have a false positive but
sometimes they have a false
a false positive so uh you know looking
right on
this side i don't want to scare you what
makes you think that
what makes you think that this one the
the negative read is is
accurate i hope it is don't get me wrong
but no it's just because separate test
was wrong in the beginning
you know yeah very different type tests
though and these are just different
tests and we just did a news conference
here in ohio where i had
dr peter muller up there answering the
questions to the ohio media and he just
explained the difference between these
two type tests
and one is a gold standard test that
most people get frankly
the only reason that i guess the white
house wanted us to take this quick test
yesterday was because it was a quick
test
i don't think it's the same test uh that
is offered when someone goes
and sees the president at the white
house i think that's that is a different
test is my understanding
so uh
you mentioned you don't want a false
positive and i get that
but a lot of people get a combination of
tests a variety of them
and they enter into the number of cases
that are reported in this country
could it be possible that we might have
a false
high count on cases because uh people
are unaware sometimes of the tests that
they're taking just that they found out
oh my gosh
i just tested positive for the virus
could that be possible
in your state and indeed in the country
well i think anything's possible
i don't think uh it's likely to be a
very big
percentage just from talking to the
doctors and the scientists i mean one
thing we do in ohio
uh is we if it's a case then
only one individual can be a case so
when we report
cases uh there's only one individual uh
test if you just report tests yes that
would be if someone got three tests then
it
you know shows up as three three
separate times but as far as the
accuracy
uh the test the type test that i got
at ohio state yesterday uh is the test
that most ohioans get it's the test that
we think better than 90 at least better
than 90 of ohioans have gotten the 1.3
million
so those are very very very accurate uh
highly accurate
uh the antigen test that was a the quick
test that was done early on
uh that day in cleveland was not as
accurate
there are some quick tests i'm told that
they're much more accurate than
than that particular test but to most
people governor
just take one test whatever it is they
find it oh my gosh so i tested positive
then they immediately go
seek treatment and handling this do you
think a good many have done that and
that might might i
you know i know what you were mentioning
about the percentages they be
giving us um a false sense of alarm here
well i think one thing we have to be
very careful of is these
antigen tests are relatively new tests
they've not been deployed very
widespread i know they certainly have
not been deployed very widespread in
ohio
and this is an example of how we will
have to be very careful with how we use
them there may be
a place to use them uh but you know
we've seen that obviously that you know
this one did not work
and it gave us a false a false read all
right
well i'm glad you're okay when i heard
that you first before the press got into
this that you called your seven children
and you wanted to talk to your
grandchildren
i thought to myself just calling all
those people is gonna take hours
um i'm glad everything worked out thank
you very much i got them called
i got them called quick thanks neil
governor thank you continued good health
thank you